alrighty just
realizing
come
on this
thing why is it doing let come on pin
the comment pin the comment come
on why are you not giving me the option
to pin my own
comment why are you not letting me do
that I can pin other people's messages
why can't I pin mine what the YouTube
what did you do
now the
[__]
okay I don't know why I can't pin my own
freaking
comment
ah God everything sucks
now like all the platforms
suck search engines
suck they keep redesigning them because
they brought in somebody new to manage
things and people have to redesign stuff
so it looks like they did something and
they can say what initiatives they
launched even though it's not helpful
and everything is
worse I know this is gonna
sound like
uh like me just blaming Capital Cap
capitalism uh capitalism for everything
but it actually is capitalism's fault
because there are people at tech
companies
who their job should just be to make
sure that the stuff that works continues
to work but they do these massive
overhauls and they change all this stuff
and it's all worse and I talked about
some of it with um inhi ification but
even beyond that you just have people
who change things because they have to
they have to look like they're doing
something otherwise they get fired
because capitalism
sucks
okay I don't really do predictions
danger Dave I don't know if you're new
around these parts I generally don't do
predictions I generally don't do
speculation
um the short version of uh for why is
just because of the way my brain's
wired I just I'm bad at it I can't
there's a part of my brain if I try and
do speculation I'm not going to say
never but like unless something really
clicks or snaps into place which is rare
then I can't even really force myself to
do speculation because there's a part of
my brain that is screaming at me the
whole time going why are you wasting
your thinking
power excuse me
IAM why are you wasting your thinking
power on trying to guess at what's going
to come next just watch the damn thing
when it comes out and I can't shut that
part of my brain off so I don't really
do predictions I don't really do
speculation as a general rule in the
year
2525 I am not sure I know that song
Dharma it's about 5050 with uh with your
choices I have to
admit
sorry just there we go there is that I'm
just juggling a couple things I'm still
here I promise
but you know this is this believe it or
not this is not the only thing going on
in my life at any given time sucks that
our flag means death got the axe I heard
about that earlier today um I haven't
finished the second season I watched the
first episode and it was fine um but it
didn't put me in a mood to binge through
it and then I had other stuff to do
[Music]
so I I haven't seen the rest I did I did
hear and this was nice because I did
wonder about this I did hear the second
season ends in a way that could be taken
as an ending unlike the first season
that was very much a cliffhanger so
that's good at least Small Favors did I
watch the ball drop I did it's a ball it
goes down and you count down and then
you pass out
that's it's the same thing every year uh
if if you're watching it on
TV um have you played microscope and
more generally do you enjoy World
building games of which is an example
I've never heard of it and no World
building games generally aren't my forte
cuz they're a bit too
open-ended um aside from the first
person perspective which is the other
reason I won't ever take up Minecraft
but one of the reasons I don't really
have a draw towards Minecraft is you
tell me I can do anything and you don't
just like be like here here's something
you can do I need objectives when it's
too open-ended I get Choice paralysis
and I do not have
fun what's tonight I don't know whatever
whatever topics come
up I'm not answering that Miss Wicked
Wolf oh the choice of water it is in
fact
water sometimes it actually
is what is my favorite version of Power
Rangers the only version I ever saw any
episodes of was Mighty Morphin and that
was not a lot I was a couple of years
older than the Target
demographic so um I didn't I didn't I
didn't get into it really at any point
it actually is M Wicked Wolf so sorry to
disappoint you ever thought of doing a
video on your favorite episode for each
doctor would be neat to see um yes but
the thing is I need to see everything CU
like I could do it but the problem is
with the classic doctors at least
there's still enough holes in my viewing
experience that I might I I might not
yet have seen what will be my favorite
like the only classic doctor that I've
seen every episode of is the sixth
doctor and for doing him I might just
cheat and go with big finish
because none of those are great I guess
mind warp might
be that might be the best
one even with its crap
ending I don't know man six doctor was
rough
R mind was a tech on the big ball drop
for years it's pretty cool getting his
behind the scenes updates other than
that man yeah I lived in New York I
never had the desire to actually try and
go to Time Square to see the thing like
I've been out at parties on New Year's
and that could be fun the idea of being
in Time Square though I I do not
understand why people do that I really
don't I don't get the appeal it it
really does seem like something that
people do just to say that they did it
I'm like you know you could just say
that you did it without doing it if the
only appeal you have is to go I did that
one time just lie it's a zero Stak Sly
who
cares do I listen to Green Day not
currently I haven't really at all but
you know I know some of their
stuff I was more of a Ninja Turtles fan
the Power Rangers honestly I mean so was
I but again Ninja Turtles hit their big
stride and their big burst on the scene
before so that's virtue of me being
slightly older
I just realized in two months you will
reach the age where you'll be the answer
to the ultimate question of life the
universe and
everything two months and uh a week and
a
bit uh caroan will not be joining us uh
if you if you follow me on Twitch she
did join the last twitch stream um so
she's starting to come back for uh for
some of the streams but she wasn't fing
up for the live stream for this one um
she sends her regards to everybody I saw
the Ricky D special I saw the Ricky JY
special uh you have my sympathies and
you may be entitled to
compensation did I watch the Golden
Globes no
never literally never
never I I like I literally could not
care
less Supreme
Omega fans complain about the Ewoks but
my own issue with returning the Jedi
that it is no Arc for Leia and Han you
can tell Harrison Ford is bored at this
point yeah like the the major problem
and what you're talking about kind of um
it's in the mix with what I think is the
major problem of Return of the Jedi
which is that it basically becomes only
Luke's
story like the other characters are
there but the only narrative really
getting
satisfactory closure and being addressed
fully is Luke's and not really anybody
else's like they're there and they're
they're used to varying you know degrees
well or not well but it by the third one
it's only Luke's story and that that
does hurt it a bit and I think what
you're talking about is is in the mix
with that
issue 42 and a week and a half for me oh
well I'll be in good company
then am I planning to watch
Eko I'm gonna try I'm annoyed that they
dropped the entire thing at once I'm
really I'm so over the binge watch model
like at this point and I grant part of
this is because it's my job if I'm going
to talk about this stuff that I need to
watch them and it's just harder for me
to carve out you know six to nine hours
at a block to try and cut through the
thing as quickly as I can rather than
like an hour a week so at this point it
is partially professional that it annoys
me when they do this but like just the
idea of and here watch it all at once I
don't
[Music]
wna I just don't
wanna H have I ever heard of nean cat
yes of course I've heard of nean cat I
exist on the internet yes I
have uh finally watched Barbie last
night well I hope you enjoyed it more
than I did
Dara seems like most people did I've
been worried about Carolin haven't seen
them in ages they they're doing they're
doing okay Molly they they had they had
some health stuff that needed time it
needed time um you know to to work on
and get better as I said she started
showing up
um uh for the twitch streams um so we've
just started like with her working on
trying to come back for the streams
again um but we're not we're not rushing
it we're not pushing it uh too hard
because her health is
important
uh I love chillian Anderson's vagina
gown okay that I missed that I need to
look up hold
on Jillian
Anderson Golden Globes 2024 let me see
this thing let let what what are we
talking about
here am I missing
something
oh there it is I had to see it under the
right
[Laughter]
lighting oh bless that
woman oh that's
fantastic thank you for bringing that to
my attention goer that
that that's
fantastic see Peter you say Echo is only
five episodes that's five
hours that's five hours that for me to
jump on this as quickly as the algorithm
is going to want me to that's five hours
I need to cut out of a single
day do you have five hours you can just
cut out of your day you know a day that
you would already you already have other
crap to do and I have a lot of crap to
do finally snowed in my area well I hope
you enjoy
it uh you know what surreal experience I
had recently my brother came over while
we were babysitting his girls and one of
them ran up and said are we going home
Daddy and I thought he can't be your
daddy he's my big
brother i' I've heard those kinds of
thoughts being had by by people before
I'm an only child so so I I can't vouch
for
that I know I recognize the art St on
some of the S man comics I recently
looked at from somewhere so I Googled
Kelly Jones and yep he did some of the
Batman El
worlds there's there some really
talented artists worked on
Sandman I'm actually quite a big fan of
Sam Sam Keith who's had a very
interesting career
by the way you helped me come out do
years ago you can know how Greatful am
oh well uh laury or laurelai I'm not
sure how you prefer to have it
pronounced um I'm glad that anything
that I ever put out into the world was
ever helpful to anyone so thank
you
Peter I I don't know what you think
you're trying to accomplish by basically
telling telling me that I have no right
to be annoyed that something is being
dropped as a binge because oh not every
episode is a is a full hour and it's
only five I don't
care like I don't I don't know what
you're trying to
accomplish arguing with me about this
it's asking for a large chunk of my life
instead of a small chunk of my life once
a week it's asking for a larger chunk of
My Life all at once and I don't want to
give it that I'm still going to try but
I'm going to be annoyed about
it please accept that I'm going to be
annoyed about
it you know binge culture is bad when
five hours is considered nothing I mean
I like the thing is it's odd to me that
anybody other than Netflix is still
doing the binge thing like them I still
kind of get cuz like it's their whole it
was like we'll put them on the map so
they're I feel like they're still kind
of married to it but like everybody else
stop like don't
stop of the past for Doctor Who episodes
which one was your favorite like you're
asking me for my single favorite of all
time last time I did a ranking it was
the doctor falls but I don't know it
changes did you hear when goodomens 3
was announced yes I did that Bookworm
and I yes I am very happy for that fact
I'm attempting to full start to finish
watch of Doctor Who which so far was
taking me so long even though I love the
first doctor
stuff Louise I whenever I hear somebody
say they're doing that my first my first
gut instinct is to just go don't just
stop don't do that
I Jesse keeps talking about doing
that do I ever indulge in fan casting no
for largely the same reason why I don't
indulge in speculation or um or
predictions U but also just
because i' I'd rather I'd rather just
wait and see who gets cast and then have
an opinion on that I think and this
isn't why I don't do predictions or fan
casting but it's like a nice side
benefit
it results in a situation where I don't
get annoyed because I thought my idea
was better which I see happen a lot with
people who do fan casting and a lot of
prediction stuff not 100% of the time
but it's pretty
common I seriously love a good binge I
used to wait for the entire season to be
done to watch a show the only reason I
don't is for the
reviews
I just I binging binging was something I
did in my
20s it's
just it's just sounds exhausting like
the very notion have I ever visited
England yes
I
um I I
visited
London
uh
two 2008
I
believe thing is I've seen it all before
so it's mostly me trying to see how
everything flows in order and give
certain stories a second third Etc pass
with a new lens okay that okay that that
makes more sense to
me Caitlyn dver is playing Ali in the
last of a season I saw that casting
I don't know who she is and I didn't
play The Last of Us Part Two so like I
know I know that was a character
that toxic Fanboys got real weird about
two times
over
so good luck to her I
suppose uh there's a lot of classic who
yeah there is they released all of it on
BBC player here I saw a few Tom Baker
and a couple Patrick trouton as well as
the three doctor special with Omega yep
there's there's a lot I've got a list of
what I haven't seen
yet and over here in in the states tub
is now carrying Doctor Who but more
importantly it's carrying the uh
animated Recreations of classic which
Brit box doesn't so I'll be able to get
some of
those the only show I've ever been watch
was Breaking Bad and only because the
Cliffhangers were so
good I mean I've binged stuff before and
like well before this was my job but
again it just feels like something that
was better suited for my 20s it like it
just feels exhausting to even think
about
now Supreme
Omega back with the Super Chat also on
the topic of the of uh Return of the
Jedi another issue I have is the sibling
reveal It's oddly pointless you would
think Leia would be more horrified in
discovering Vader's her her dad yeah it
really has no impact on anything it's
very it's a very strange reveal in
hindsight like I I grew up on it like
the first three Star Wars movies I don't
remember watching for the first time so
I never had to process that as a reveal
it just kind of was that was just a fact
of my
existence that they were brother and
sister but it's it's it's a weird reveal
cuz it
impacts nothing I guess the only thing
it does is
it it makes it no longer a question of
fan preference the fact that Leia ends
up with
Han um because she's not going to she's
not going to get with her brother so
like it just kind of closes that door
and like okay she's with Han I was like
okay you forced it it's by default but
okay other than that like actual impact
on the characters is damn near nothing
sorry I meant the past four episodes of
Doctor Who oh uh wild blue
yonder a toxic fans and stands the same
thing not always but
frequently stands are a very specific
stripe of fan who can often become toxic
because STS are people who get like
obsessive about a thing but not all
toxic fans are obsessive some toxic fans
are just toxic who happen to be fans of
a thing being a St of something involves
a level of obsession that is not
required to be toxic so it's a vend
diagram with a lot of crossover but
they're not quite synonymous I
physically own all of the first and
second do stop from the Blu-ray sets for
the rest that are out we'll see how much
I watch the seasons I don't own if I
make it that far well best of luck I'm
too 0hd to binge I usually can't make it
through one episode without distracting
myself well that's
a oh that's a whole other kettle of fish
prequel trilogy or sequel
Trilogy what between the between the two
for Star Wars um neither Rogue one
um if the doctor was real and asked you
to be his next companion would you take
him up on the offer I honestly don't
know I honestly don't
know I'm old I'm old and I have a kid to
raise would feel very
um
irresponsible the completionist in me
can't just watch individual episodes I
have to watch the entire season SLS
series I used to be like
that but at some point in my 30s like
something clicked and I'm like I don't
actually have to do that and yeah I
don't I don't have that completion
Instinct anymore I haven't for a while
now
uh
here's the title for a video analyzing
the 13th Doctor 13th Doctor The Good The
Bad and The Unlucky I I guess you could
I have no particular desire to do a
dissection of the 13th
Doctor I don't really want to
revisit the chibal era anymore than I
already
have and some fans aren't even much of a
fan to begin with that's why I'm a treky
oh oh I wish I didn't know what that was
in reference to goer unfortunately I
[Music]
do
yeah I mean that
like especially when you're dealing with
influencers that's a whole special
strata of toxic fan where the fan is in
quotes and these are just people who
want to
be toxically vitriolic against what they
view as woke and they will claim to be a
fan to claim space and Shout in fan
spaces
but is Rogue one my favorite of the ones
that aren't the original Three yeah
probably I willever be upset that the
13th series which feature the 13th
doctor did not have 13 episodes alas
alas andor's hands down my favorite Star
Wars show I think Andor is the only Star
Wars show I actually like granted I have
not seen all of them but most of the
ones I haven't seen it's because I
started to watch them and went I'm not
enjoying this or at least I'm not
enjoying this enough for it to be worth
my time like that's the thing when you
work when you have turned your your the
things that you used to do in your free
time into your job and you work from
home
and you have to go so far out of your
way to stop working which is just that's
just my life at this point um it becomes
a lot easier to walk away from stuff CU
again like 10 years
ago I probably would have given like at
this point my line is usually three
episodes if I'm three episodes in and
it's starting to feel like
work I I probably will bail I used to
give things a full
season I don't have the time for that
anymore I have the time or the energy
for that I value my time a lot more now
that I work from home and I literally
instead of sitting down watching this I
could be doing something productive
right now so while there are some
hazards to working from home and being
self-employed um it has literally made
me value my time more highly than I used
to my most disappointing film
ever I don't
know
probably I don't know it would probably
either
be the last Jedi or
Spectre I really wanted to like the Last
Jedi and I just don't I've tried I've
tried I can't I don't like it and
Spectre was an amazing James Bond movie
for about an hour and then it
became so
bad
ah why is the 10th doctor so loved I
like him but Capaldi all the way I I
don't know Matt I think part of it is
just spill over love for David Tenant as
a person person which you know fine
valid do I think jod Whitaker will get a
reprisal when she makes a reappraisal
when she makes big finish
audios
I short answer
no because what you need to
realize that the the two doctors that
got major reappraisals thanks to Big
finish were the eighth doctor and the
sixth doctor but what you need to
realize was the case when they started
doing big finish stuff that is not the
case now was there was no
show so a lot more fans either listened
to or became aware of that was the thing
that was going on now I don't want to
make it sound like nobody's listening to
Big Finnish anymore they absolutely are
but it's not going to have the same
impact
because people who might benefit from
whatever she ends up doing with big
finish if she chooses to work for with
she might not let's not treat it
automatically as a foregone conclusion I
don't think that's been announced or
confirmed but um if she ever chooses to
if the show is still
running
then it it's just it's just a situation
where a lot of people are going to go oh
well like I'm just watching the show
fine she's doing her own thing whatever
whereas when sixth doctor and eighth
doctor started doing big finish
that was the doctor who that was
available I mean like also the Seventh
Doctor The Fifth Doctor were doing it as
well but like that's what there was so a
lot
more people were willing to give it a
shot where I don't think as many people
are going to feel that's the case oh no
comment shck hi welcome to the chat nice
to have you
here how do you do fellow fans yeah yeah
any particular six doctor
recommendations outside of Jubilee and
holy Terror um what's the I think the
other
one uh the Marian conspiracy that's a
pretty good one that's the one that
introduces Evelyn SMI um who is by far
the six doctor's um best
companion and I would argue as one of
the best companions in Doctor Who she's
amazing and that's her
introduction YouTube's been annoying for
me uh at the moment so I'm off I'm sorry
to hear that Stephen thanks for stopping
in I gotta check out the Discord in a
moment but let me see if I can catch up
real
quick I'm 26 and I've never seen Star
Wars you got a ways to go I know people
who are 41 and I've never seen Star Wars
so there's probably
um there probably folks older than
that are you even aware of the movie
Lady B lady Ballers I'm aware I don't
care best dinosaur movie original King
Kong
uh Jesse jenders and arono has a
fantastic six-hour video on Star Wars I
highly recommend yes it's very good I do
a voice in it and I do mean like
properly do a voice I got to play a
character and everything it was lovely
okay I got to check out the Discord
reminder that the uh Council of Geeks
Discord is a patreon exclusive Perkin is
the one other way aside from Super chats
that will guarantee that I will see and
respond to your question query or
thought so let me get through these as
quickly as I
can remember when I was speculating
about who doing a story where young Rose
wants to come out and the doctor goes
back in time to 2018 convinces her to do
it we both agreed it was a bad idea yes
I do remember hypothetically suppose
they did that episode and it was really
well written like suppose they got a
transperson to write or something and
it's really accurately depicts the
anxieties of queer people of regards to
coming out but all the stuff you said
about it undermining the idea of Donna
being accepting was still the case how
would you go about reviewing an episode
that's really good in isolation but
would have unwanted implications for the
rest of the
characters by pointing that
out I mean you you basically laid out
what I would say in that hypothetical
situation like this is very well handled
but and if youve see myself I whether I
like or dislike a thing I have no
problem with going well it's generally
this
but I'm quite fond of that uh you know
what's a story I've heard from several
queer people who've just come out both
sis and trans or any combination of the
two their friends and family already
suspected new but felt it wasn't their
place to say anything until they came
out themselves I get not just saying to
someone you care about yeah I think you
might be trans SL gay like that'd be
crappy but suppose you had a male friend
relative who enjoyed dressing and acting
in conventionally feminine ways and one
day uh they ask you do you think I'm an
egg how would you respond to a question
like that if asked directly
honestly I I think there is certainly a
value in stepping back and letting
people have their own Journey rather
than trying to impose your
interpretation of what you think their
life is that's something that can be
very fraught especially depending on the
nature of your relationship with them
but if somebody asks you do you think I
might be this I would say yeah answer
honestly although maybe open with well
do you think you are because that's what
is more important here I'll tell you my
thoughts but why do you think you might
be like start with it there would be my
honest uh assessment there going back to
my first question ignoring the idea of
it being Rose or anyone in specific how
would you go about casting a character
who's supposed to be a younger version
of a character who later turns out to be
transed like if it's a pre-trend
transition transfem person do you cast a
10-year-old sis boy 10-year-old sis
girl I honestly don't know largely
because the kinds of stories that tend
to
have pre-transition material with
somebody that young or indeed
pre-transition material at all are
largely stories I'm not interested in I
mean that's one of the things that I've
I've often had as a push back when
people said what we have to cast this
gender people's trans because when we
show them
pre-transition then then they have to be
convincing like first of all setting
aside the fact that whatever you're
doing to make a CIS person look trans
you can do in the opposite direction but
even setting that aside
why why do we have to see them
pre-transition and that's not to say
that there's no stories where that's
actually important but I don't know I
would need to see what the actual story
is and it and since it's not a kind of
story that I would be inclined to tell I
don't really have an assessment on it I
would need to see the nuts and bolts of
how that would actually work to have an
opinion it's one of those things once I
saw it or read it I could have an
opinion but trying to speculate on it
again it's that part of my brain that's
going like don't spend your thinking
time on this but and this time what it's
telling me is you wouldn't tell that
story so
stop uh is there any pre-established
character that Mrs flood could turn out
to be that your eyes would make up for
her being introduced as a mystery box
nope cuz you could still have revealed
her to be anybody without her being a
mystery box those are separate and
unrelated issues do you agree or
disagree with Disney's decision to
introduce shudy Goa doctor far sooner in
the Christmas special than Russell had
PR planned citation
needed uh you got to give me a source on
that because I have not heard that that
is the
case so hang on a
second
uh
um let's
see
sorry I'm just trying to Quick uh Google
Fu on
this yeah until somebody gives me a
citation for a source on that idea that
it was Disney's decision to introduce
shudy Goa early then I have no opinion
because I don't believe it like okay can
I take a quick second to address this
because this is really starting to
bother me it's showing up a lot in my
comments lately there's a lot of
conspiratorial thinking specifically in
regards to Disney um and Doctor Who
that's showing up in my comments like
tons of stuff like oh I bet Disney made
them do this oh this feels like Disney I
bet Disney had control was there is
literally no evidence that Disney has
any direct creative control over any
part of the production of Doctor Who or
any part of Russell T dav's process if I
were to give any benefit of the doubt
the one thing I would say okay maybe
there are applying some pressure on that
is the push for spin-offs because they
probably do want a whole hooniverse to
be broadcasting but until somebody
actually provides me with evidence not
speculation and not conspiratorial
nothing that Disney is actually putting
their thumb on the scale with creative
decisions please stop saying it in my
comments
okay just
stop I'm not mad at the person who asked
this question in specific but I the the
level of of heat I kind of got there for
a minute is just because I want to stop
seeing it I'm getting really irritated
by the conspiratorial thought starting
to invade my comment section and look if
you wanted to believe that any company
was going to have
actual uh control and creative influence
it would be Sony
they bought bad wolf Studios they own
it and nobody brings them up oh Disney I
get that we all hate Disney and yes
Disney sucks that doesn't make Disney
freaking
Palpatine Disney is not behind
everything you
dislike stop
it how effective do you think anti-
capitalist shows such as Swig Gam the
boys have been making people aware of
the inherent problems with capitalism I
don't
know that's a question for a
sociologist um and because like I am not
personally acquainted with anyone who
like had their eyes opened by shows like
that
um because most of my friends are
already on board with the idea that
capitalism sucks and then you know we
see these things and we're like oh boy
it's nice to see that
expressed how how good is it at um
getting people who aren't already in
that head space to go wait a minute I I
honestly don't know that's that that is
a question for a
sociologist went to see Christopher
eckleson in Christmas Carol on Saturday
it was amazing I sat on the stage there
were several interactive moments in the
play including when I got to shake
Chris's hand oh wow that's cool have you
ever been in a play that's been
[Music]
interactive no not really I've been to
some like dinner theater Productions
where like it's a it's a mystery and the
audience votes on who did it um that's
about as close as I've come I mean if
we're not counting improv which is its
whole other their own thing uh found out
my girlfriend has barely been to the
theater any recommendations on things I
could take her to in the future or a
favorite play of yours I mean it depends
on the kind of things she likes I mean
some people like huge spectacle and
there are great huge spectacle shows out
there you know whether it be lame as Rob
fan of the Opera Wicked Etc um some
people really like the the intimacy you
can get from a small show in the theater
I know that can be counterintuitive like
you're on a stage in front of a thousand
people like how can it be intimate it
can be it it legitimately can be in a
way that film kind of can't because if
it's done well you feel like you're in
the
room um so I mean favorite plays of mine
that I've seen I like Blood Brothers a
lot that's a good one it's depressing
but it's very good um trying to think
what else that I've actually
seen uh The Lion King is a hell of a
spectacle if you can get to that
anywhere yeah sure we'll just go with
that I'm not going to say those are my
favorite of all time but I came up with
a with a couple for years so there you
go well those are ah those are both
musicals though for a straight show
honestly if you find a good production
of The Children's Hour again that's
really depressing though is there a non-
depressing straight show I want to
recommend nope most of the best Straight
shows I can think of are depressing so
The Children's Hour there you go has the
MCU phased out no but it has already
peaked uh are you interested in seeing
pretty things the
film I mean
maybe
that's one of those things where like if
if one of my partners decides that they
want to see it I'll be like yeah sure
but short of that external push or
somebody paying me to see it it's not
high on my prior priority
list cold crisp mornings or Mists and
mellow
fruitfulness mellow fruitfulness I'm not
entirely sure what to make of that I'm
leaning towards the
cuz you know on a good day I'm a little
bit of a mellow fruit myself um have you
watched the original UK querist folk no
nor have I watched the American version
I've never sign seen sign I've never
seen either
one so uh I don't have a particular draw
to it because it um either version
American or UK like it's it's an aspect
of queer culture that just doesn't
interest me and I say that as someone
who literally worked in a gay bar for a
year in Boston so like I've been
in you know the
the gay bar gay club scene to a certain
extent but it's I just don't have an
interest
in in diving into that further I mean I
just don't I I lived the degree to which
I want to experience it okay I'm back in
the main chat let's see
I'm aware and I don't care sounds like a
slogan could function as
one Hyo Ren was not meant to be
redeemed who knows what was meant nobody
knew what they were
doing uh
let's
[Music]
see uh they did say Disney asked for the
opening to be changed I think that was
documented in Doctor Who magazine
somebody find me the specific Source on
that CA I I I would love to read
that um
CA I don't even remember people bring
that
up in specific
before the same before shot is excus for
um using disability disabled characters
as Oscar bait for non-disabled actors
and is always similar BS before story is
less likely to be relatable or effective
which is all nonsense it's all it's all
awful off topic but I saw your best
media of 2023 do you have plans to watch
the boy and the Heron or Godzilla minus
one if you have not already seen them I
would love to see both neither is
playing close to where I
live
so uh Disney is behind pal Palatine
though I
mean a [__] show was behind palpa how
political am I quite
not by choice by
necessity as a transperson my existence
has become political
so me trying to not be political would
be me Burying my head in the
sand and I don't and I'm not going to do
that pantomimes are usually interactive
yeah pantomimes aren't really a thing in
the US
weren't for that crazy conspiracy group
online I think the letter Q would be a
great gay or trans Shand the Q Community
Q rights Q couples Etc what do you think
would have been nice it's completely
tainted now
though
so what got me into Doctor Who
oud I got into Doctor Who because the
oud look a little like the Mind flares
um from Dungeons and Dragons and so that
that caught my attention uh flipping
through channels actually sorry I just
dropped
something actually when I was in London
back around
2008 uh was flipping through
channels and there was was a rerun of
uh um the Satan pit I saw an oud and it
looked like an athid a mind flare I was
like what is this and then I caught more
of it I'm like this seems really good I
should check this out as soon as I get
back home and I did and I fell in
love I have pretty much very low
expectations for the new Mean Girls
remake I wasn't even crazy about the
first one
oh the whole
the whole we made a movie and we made it
a musical I was already exhausted by I'm
super exhausted by the very notion of we
took a movie and made it a musical now
we're making a movie again like we did
that with the
producers like 15 years
ago and it didn't really work then so
just
DS9 is a show I have not seen
what are my thoughts on AI well I wish
that we would agree on a different term
for it because it's not actually
artificial intelligence and by and large
not 100% universally but by and
large it
sucks it sucks and it's crap and it
should mostly go away do I think that
Christmas is overc commercialized as
someone who is not a Christian I have no
opinion I have no investment in the true
meaning of Christmas therefore I do not
particularly have an opinion on whether
it's overc
commercialized I just read some Hilda
fans are shipping Freda and David
thought no and that's not me knowing the
ship I'm just saying no I have no
thought I'm not a shipper
and like fans who are at least my
experiences with them which is limited
they seem mostly harmless I don't do it
and I don't
care I don't care that other people do
what's my favorite Doctor Who comic I
have read very few Doctor Who comics so
I don't really have
one for the first time in my life I had
a book make me feel old called email an
archaic form of
communication
oh
dang yep that
hurts been wondering what's with the
mcavity at the end
so uh this goes back several years to
the uh
review that I did of the movie Cats and
that is one one of my drunk reviews I've
done not too I think I've
done four drunk review oh five drunk
reviews alog together I did a drunk
review of the first two episodes
of uh the Inhumans I did a drunk review
of cats I did a drunk review of Sonic
the Hedgehog and then over on the break
room of Geeks I was commissioned to do
drunk reviews on from Dust Till Dawn and
Blues Brothers um but one of the things
that I pointed out in the cat's review
was the character of mcavity who just at
one point literally just vanishes out of
the scene going
[Music]
mcavity and I did that at the end of
that
review and then people requested it at
at the live stream and it's it's become
a
thing
artificial incompetence now honestly
artifici what we are currently calling
AI should just be called
theft it's theft it's technologically
facilitated
theft what's worse a Mean Girls movie
musical or Wicked being broken into two
parts I don't know they're both bad
ideas I do like musicals being made into
movies for accessibility for peeps who
can't get to the theater still not sold
on regular movies being made into
musicals so I kind of get that Hypno
Amber it's like
it's that's the one thing that I will
grant that theater is kind of by its
nature a little bit of an exclusionary
medium because if you do not live in the
areas where the show is being performed
you can't see it that having been
said I would rather more effort is done
to more often make available taped
recordings like what was done with
Hamilton or like what was done with cats
in the90s like it used to be a lot more
standard I feel like it's happening less
and less and that maybe the actually
adapting them into movies proper is
taking its place and I I still don't
like it
fundamentally it's all Snapchat and Tik
Tok now is Snapchat actually like I
still have the app don't get me wrong
but I feel like Snapchat isn't really
that much of a thing
anymore will I ever do a drunk review
again oh
probably somebody will probably
commission me to do a drunk review will
you still take commissions for drunk
reviews
yep uh you don't get when you commission
a drunk review you do not commission
what I'm drinking I will still have full
control over that you're just deciding
the movie and that I will review it
while drunk that is what you are
commissioning what I am drunk
on that will be up to me and me
alone but at present I don't have plans
for more drunk
reviews your community is great to talk
to I appreciate you answering questions
from us oh thank you danger Dave I'm
glad you're having a good time
hereabouts from the views I've seen
drunk would be the best way to watch
watch the cats
movie it didn't
hurt it didn't hurt how do you edit
drunk reviews how do you stand
it I
don't like drunk reviews are very
lightly
edited I mean at this point most review
stuff and drunk reviews included go up
in the break room of
Geeks those are very lightly edit edited
anyways I really only cut something out
if like
I I had to stop like because I coughed
or to double
check um usually in performer's name or
um like I lost a thought and it took me
a second to come back but most of those
like you go through the break room of
Geeks and see the review material a lot
of it you will notice there is no cut
it's just me rambling for 14 to 20
minutes ah Supreme Omega back again
thank you very much I appreciate
it uh if you want to have one legit
criticism with Lucas is that he never
made the unaltered theatrical versions
of the original trilogy widely available
yeah yeah and I will always have an
issue with
that um there are other forms of
so-called AI that aren't theft per se
though they have related problems like
AI uh in policing while uh reproducing
existing
biases well that's not that's that's
algorithmic though and they're calling
it AI to jump onto a buzzword right now
ai is mostly being used for generative
Ai and the algorithmic stuff being
programmed in to uh police related
Tech um that's that's algorithm classic
that's that's not stepping up to the
level of generative AI at least so far
as I'm aware um which is again another
reason why we need to stop Banning the
word AI about because people are
starting to slap it on stuff that's not
even the thing that isn't actually AI
that we're already calling Ai and now
we're starting to call even more things
that aren't ai ai we can't even agree on
the one wrong thing that we shouldn't be
calling it but we already
are anybody follow
that drunken high at the same time while
watching Velma nope I will not do a I
will not do a drunk review of a show
only of a movie because the way I do it
is I drink through the movie so I am
getting drunk as I watch and then I
review it immediately while still drunk
I cannot do that with a show it runs too
long you pick the movie I pick the booze
ver wild yeah uh I was eating
raspberries drunk review of wood nail
and I must have been requested at some
point not yet not yet you think so
that'd be fitting did you end up
finishing sense 8 I can't remember would
you review it on the channel um I have
not I at this point it has been enough
time has passed since I tried to start
it and it it wasn't like oh I'm not
interested I just I I didn't get back to
it I'd have to start from the beginning
again I didn't get that
far have I seen any of the show
Community nope just the
memes Community oops all memes Edition
that's that's the one I
saw
uh I kind of don't get how letting AI
use artist work hurts them like what
they create is subpar crap that's not
the point the point is is that these AIS
are currently being trained on artwork
that has not been paid for that
permission has not been given and
because generative AI cannot do what a
human can do which is to take something
as a point of inspiration but then do
something legitimately new to them with
it because of the nature of of
generative AI in that all it can do is
Cobble together a bunch of stuff that it
is seen elsewhere and spit it out in the
amalgamation that you prompted to then
it is going to
hurt it it hurts artists in multiple
ways first of all there's the jackass is
trying to use it to replace artists but
beyond
that artists are not saying hey go ahead
and train your [__] thing that you
want to use to put me out of a job on my
work none of them are saying that and in
fact a lot of these works are you
know they they are as protected as the
artist can make them but they're still
being used to train these AIS it is
still theft of your work regardless of
whether what the AI spits out or not is
actually good enough to replace you it
shouldn't we
need forgive the terminology I am about
to use but this whole nonsense with AI
we need to kill it in its in its uh
infancy the same way that we killed
nfts this needs to
die before it gets a foothold we do not
let
this we do not let this route we do not
let this get get to the point where it
is creating more than subpar stop it now
kill it
now you doged the B there with not doing
a drunk review of Elma somebody would
have to pay me my rate for reviewing uh
a full season of TV which is
significantly more U expensive than
getting me to review a single episode of
TV to get me to watch Velma I will not
watch it
otherwise drunk review of the anime
Titanic movies I'd probably turn that
down even if commissioned because
like and this is not me being like Oh
Nostalgia Critic already did them so I
didn't want to but like most of the
reason anybody knows about those at all
is because of nostalgia critic reviews
and then it's then I I feel like I'm
just stepping on somebody else's stuff
that's not about respect to as a
Nostalgia Critic I don't have a ton but
I try and have some professional
courtesy what's the worst fan base
you've ever come
across here's a weird answer for you and
this is based purely off personal
experience and I am not going to negate
anyone else's experience and I'm not
going to say that this is worse than
what other people have experienced from
other fandoms but inside number
nine the inside number nine fans alone
put me off that show I watched the first
series I gave my thoughts on it and the
fans found my reviews and I have no
interest in watching anymore cuz if
that's the kind of person who loves this
show I don't want it and I probably
would have liked it but I don't want to
watch it fans put me off
it what was nft non-fungible tokens
watch um folding ideas video line goes
up it's two hours and it's amazing but
it'll uh catch you up on what those
are I watched the zoologist argue with
chat GPT that's another thing stop using
chat GP G PT as a gimmick like the these
stuns like I I got chat GPT to do to to
do this and I argue with chat GPT like
stop using it just stop just stop using
it the stuff is culturally destructive
by its nature stop using it
stop which is worse an earworm of show
tune or an earworm of a parody of a show
tune
it really depends on the
specifics if Google is going to take my
writing from Google Docs then I just
write fanfic is what I'm current is what
I'm currently
doing I mean that's fine but
they they still should not be yanking
your work to train this stuff but they
are what was it about inside number n n
fans um the slightest critique of any
the instant I said anything was other
than perfect Not only was I called the
usual slew of uh transphobic things I
was also called a massive idiot because
I clearly was too stupid to get it I'm
like oh this is the kind of person this
show attracts no I'll pass I'll
pass all we should be more wary of AI we
all should be more wary of Ai and what
it could do to people's lives in the
near future I mean like it's it's just
it's
just all right here's what I will
say I wouldn't care about
AI if we didn't live under
capitalism
oo hot take
basically if we did not have to earn
money to make a living and in order to
not die in this
Society then I would say don't worry
about
AI but the fact that it
can destroy livelihoods if it hits the
level of saturation and ubiquity that
its evangelists wanted to
have no kill it either kill it or get us
out of capitalism altogether there's the
tradeoff there's the trade-off if we
dismantle capitalism as a whole and
install something that is not causing us
to tear at each other's throats and have
to burn ourselves out for a minimum 40
hours a week just to be able to live uh
with a roof over our heads and some kind
of sustenance to be able to eat then I
would not care nearly as
much always found it weird the way
inside number nine fans tend to act like
black mirror is trash to make their show
look better yeah that kind of does sum
them up in a nutshell doesn't
it Sunday from Sunday in the park with
George versus Sunday from Tick Tick boom
I do not know Sunday in the park with
George so
sorry Sunday is an okay song for tick
Tick boom Tick Tick boom has a few great
songs that's that's an okay
one I think stopping AI written content
is probably
impossible
uh I mean the main thing
that and and there is there may not be a
solution to this and honestly I hope
there isn't and I am going to wrap it up
soon
um but the uh the thing about AI written
content and hopefully there is never a
solution to
this uh it can't tell truth
truth AI generative AI like chat GPT
doesn't know what a fact is it only
knows what a fact looks like as was
stated by uh H bomber guy but it doesn't
know what truth
is it only knows what uh a result from a
when given a certain prompt what a
correct result would look like and read
like that doesn't mean that it ever
speak
truth and this is why you get things
like lawyers getting torn a new one in
court because they let chat gbt Write a
brief and submitted it to the court with
fake case names and fake reference
numbers for the cases and it looked
correct because it knew how to format it
but it doesn't know anything it doesn't
know what anything is or means or what
the truth is and similarly there was a
newspaper some some local newspaper like
ran a story about uh a murder uh in like
the town NE the next town over or
something that was generated by chat
gbt it was a murder that didn't happen
but Chad GPT knew what a salacious front
page story looked like so it created one
none of it was
true it didn't matter it doesn't know
how to be
truthful and I hope they never figure
out how to fix that CU that will be the
one thing that we will always have over
Ai and that's that is something that
will limit its use that will still
create problems in Creative Works yes
still that's why the unions matter
that's why the wga strike was so
important but yeah oh hey me I didn't
see you pop in I had a boss that loved
Jimmy Buffett and played his Christmas
stuff really the worst to listen to
because I couldn't even man manag to
ignore it ooh yikes yeah okay that's o
That's a lot to put up
with I genuinely think abolishing
capitalism is more plausible and I mean
uh that to me as pessimistic as it
sounds
yeah you may be
right I mean it basically is uh coyote
aul it's again to to steal observation
from H bomber guy it's basically a fancy
version of just hitting the predictive
text button on your phone over and over
and over and over
again it's a fancy version of that
that's kind of all it is the one thing
in Gremlins 2 that's aged the worse is
having a trump analog guy turns out to
be a good guy see the thing is I like
I'm not going to say there's no Trump in
there I always read him as a lot more
Ted Turner than I did Trump though and
maybe I'm alone in
that but he always struck me as more
Turner than
Trump like he
has the thing
about uh Daniel
clamp who is the the character we're
referring to in Gremlins 2 is that he is
not malicious he's actually part of his
problem is he's
bored and he just wants stuff to do
but he's rich and so what he does is you
know owns TV networks and this
ridiculous building and do building
projects because that's like there's a
there's a
[Music]
certain Glee to him that is devoid of
even parodies of trump so that's like
and that that and that always struck me
honestly is way more Ted Turner like yes
there's some Trump in there because he
is a developer um and which is something
I don't think Ted Turner's ever been but
there's a lot of emphasis on like owning
the uh the cable channels and wanting to
colorize black and white movies and that
was all Ted Turner's thing
so yeah I I guess it doesn't bug me
because I never saw him as only Trump in
the first
place a drunk watch of curse of the fail
death might be fun it might be if I
didn't think that was a deeply
overrated comedy bit that is not all
that funny
anyways
um I am going to wrap it up there uh but
thank you very much for joining me first
stream of the New Year 2024 I hope it is
treating you well so far if it hasn't
been I hope it starts treating you
better and um uh stuff coming up
tomorrow I am streaming on Twitch more
balers Gate 3 also tomorrow there will
be a new video out on this channel on uh
the movie The Gray specifically the
ending um which I think is fantastic and
I found an excuse to talk about it so
I'm gonna um and Saturday I don't want
to say what Saturday's video is because
I haven't shot it yet I actually need to
try and do that after I get off stream
and on the off chance that I don't that
I end up changing topics or pivoting to
something else or something happens I
don't want to say what it's currently
planned to be but uh that's that's
what's coming up in the immediate so
thank you very much um take care of
yourselves be well be safe be kind
please remember that you are beautiful
you are valid and you are loved you are
the council and I am just running the
meetings and until next time this
council is
adjourned
mavity